so I'm a big fan of cinema Godard used
to say cinema is truth 24 times per
second now cinema is a technology of
immersion that allows us to lose
ourselves it's a portal to another world
cinema trades and subjectivity now
cinema only works through a phenomenon
known as the deictic shift the directed
ship is the point in which the viewer
assumes the viewpoint of the character
and at that moment you get into the
world as world you enter the dream
inception happens now this directive is
associated with diminished activity in
the lateral prefrontal cortex which is
responsible for your sense of body
awareness of self-awareness so you
literally assume a viewpoint of the
character mentally you start living
vicariously through that character and
you forget your body that is the moment
in which we trade in subjectivity you
become someone else and the catharsis
you get to have that hero's journey
that's one of the most intoxicating
delicious things ever now imagine this
this hunger for this kind of immersion
and how it might catalyze these new
emerging technologies of virtual reality
you know what happens when you move into
a world like the 1998 movie strange days
when you were literally wired tripping
you were jacked in this isn't TV only
better but this is a piece of somebody's
life the trailer of that movie was like
I am your priest I am your shrink I'm
your main connection to the switchboard
of souls cinema media becomes the Santa
Claus of the subconscious you say it you
even think it you could have it
certainly says something about what it
means to be human our desire to to
experience intersubjectivity to see the
world through the eyes of other but it's
fascinating nonetheless I'm not judging
I just think it's uh who we are
[Music]